[Musique]
sacré à la question de l'emploi ce soir
on reçoit donc jean noël barrot
secrétaire général du mouvement
démocrate député des yvelines
vice président de la commission des
finances économiste et la députée
michèle de vaucouleurs député des
yvelines membre de la commission des
affaires sociales alors l'an le travail
son organisation son contenu c'est une
question éminemment politique qui
structure la société
et durant ces cinq années durant le
premier quinquennat donc d' emmanuel
macron on voit que l'emploi est en nette
amélioration
on a dans ce dernier trimestre de 2021
une baisse de 5,9 pour cent du chômage
ça correspond à environ 208 milles
inscrits en moins par rapport aux 3
millions 3 de chômeurs l'emploi sur les
cinq années est amélioré de 3 7% c'est
nettement plus que durant l'e3
quinquennat précédent donc depuis 15 ans
on n'a pas eu un taux de chômage aussi
bas alors pour autant on voit qu'il
reste des questions des inquiétudes dans
une partie de la population
mais
cette hausse de l'emploi ne s'est pas
accompagnée s'est pas accompagnée d'une
dégradation du pouvoir d'achat ni de la
profitabilité des entreprises donc on a
des progrès structurelles qu'on peut
mettre au jour jean noël va nous
expliquer notamment comment à la fois la
baisse des impôts la réforme du marché
du travail le plan de relance conjugué
ont vraiment permis de donner un élan ce
l'emploi et donc de permettre une vision
action efficace de ceux de ce premier
quinquennat qui va être poursuivi à leur
première question peut-être pour
jean-noël la première dans la campagne
qui vient de se clore on a vu beaucoup
le thème du pouvoir d'achat et puis
finalement cette question du chômage n'a
même pas été tellement mise en avant par
les oppositions comme si le même les
oppositions reconnaissait que la
réellement on a une amélioration sur le
plan de l'emploi
oui mais si olivia bonjour à toutes et à
tous et un plaisir de vous retrouver
pour ce
rendez-vous
démocrate abdou est effectivement sur le
front de l'emploi la situation malgré
les crises qu'on a traversé est assez
bonne puisque que l'a rappelé olivia le
chômage est au plus bas depuis 15 ans le
chômage des jeunes est au plus bas
depuis 40 ans pendant les cinq années
qui viennent de s'écouler est à nouveau
en dépit des crises
l'économie française a créé
1,2 million d'emplois et ça c'est pour
les volumes et pour là je dirais pour
les quantités mais pour la qualité ce
qui est intéressant c'est que depuis
2010 est s'est interrompue l'hémorragie
d'emplois industriels
qu'on a connue pendant deux décennies
puisque l'emploi industriel entre en
2000 entre 2017 et 2019 s'est remis à
augmenter avant de baisser pendant la
crise de l'aco vide et de retrouver son
niveau de 2010 est donc c'est des
indicateurs qui sont intéressants et je
trouve qu'ils sont d'autant plus
intéressants qu'en réalité cette
politique qui a été menée pour y
parvenir avec comme tu l'as dit la
réforme du marché du travail qui a rendu
plus fluide le lait le travail de
ressources humaines et les le dialogue
social la réforme de l'apprentissage
bien sûr qui a permis de déverrouiller
cette modalité dans bausch qui était
très largement utilisé dans le jeu dans
les pays voisins de la france mais mais
que la france n'utiliserait que trop peu
que les entreprises de france d'utiliser
trop peu et puis effectivement les
baisses d'impôts pour les entreprises
d'abord la baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés qui était une promesse de
campagne d' emmanuel macron 2017 et puis
dans le cadre du plan de relance la
baisse des impôts de production qui a
permis de
effectivement de redonner de l'air à
l'industrie
ce qui est intéressant quand on regarde
les choses c'est que cette politique qui
vise le qui vise le plein emploi et qui
a été très fortement attaqué très
durement attaqué pendant la crise comme
étant une politique de la france des
métropoles de la france des riches et
qui a conduit certains de ses opposants
a
nommé le président va désigner le
président de la république comme le
président des riches en réalité elles
ont bénéficié aux français et aux
territoires les plus fragiles
quand on regarde les départements dans
lesquels le chômage a le plus baissé
depuis 2010 7 est bien plus le
département est pauvre plus le taux de
pauvreté au départ en 2017 et élevé dans
le département et plus la baisse du
chômage a été prononcé et on voit la
même chose avec les créations d'emplois
les créations d'emplois donc j'ai dit
qu'un million et un million deux
d'emplois ont été créés sous le
quinquennat d'emmanuel ma grand voile à
la croissance de l'emploi s'est à peu
près 3% sur sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat c'est deux fois plus dans
les dix départements de france qui sont
qui étaient les plus pauvres en 2017 et
quant à l'emploi industriel qui comme je
les dis à augmenter un peu au début puis
à baisser si bien que en moyenne il est
stable sur l'ensemble des cinq ans qu'on
vient de traverser
il augmente très fortement là aussi dans
les dix départements les plus pauvres de
france et donc on voit bien comment la
poursuite de l'objectif du plein emploi
est une est une politique qui est une
politique économique certes mais qui
aussi une politique de justice sociale
et de justice territoriale alors
maintenant évidemment il faut aller plus
loin et il faut passer je dirai au
niveau national maintenant qu'on a fait
le passage de 9 à 7 % de chômage bien il
faut aller de cette portion de chômage à
5 % de chômage c'est-à-dire atteindre le
niveau de certains de nos voisins et
pour ça ça va être évidemment un peu
plus difficile parce qu'il est toujours
moins compliqué de faire baisser le
chômage quand il est très élevé que
quand ils commencent déjà à être
proche du plein emploi et pour ça il va
falloir maintenir les baisses d'impôts
aller plus loin sur les impôts de
production c'est c'était l'un des
engagements de deux campagnes d'emmanuel
maquereau en 2022 la suppression de la
cvae notamment mais il va falloir aussi
travaillé sur les difficultés de
recrutement c'est à dire la rencontre
entre les demandeurs d'emploi et les
offres d'emploi disponibles pour les
entreprises et faire en sorte que la
formation et l'orientation serait
nettement renforcée mais on pourrait en
dire un mot si si tu veux olivier un peu
plus tard merci beaucoup avait
l'apprentissage on va en parler tout à
l'heure et effectivement dans son
rapport que tu as remis au premier
ministre sur le rebond économique
territoriale tu montre effectivement que
c'est à ce paradoxe on s'imagine pas qu
effectivement ce sont les dix
départements les plus pauvres qui se
sont redressés deux fois plus vite mais
c'est effectivement une réalité il ya
une sorte de résurrection de certains
sites industriels
délaissé donc c'est vraiment
effectivement un objectif de cohésion
sociale comme tu es comme tu le rappelle
michel de ton côté tu as aussi
travailler justement beaucoup sur ces
questions d'emploi notamment sur la
question du rsa et l'action du retour à
l'emploi là aussi on a vu que ça durant
la campagne le sujet a été soulevé donc
voilà comment accompagner au mieux ce
retour à l'emploi de ceux qui en sont
encore le plus éloigné est ce que tu
peux nous dire quelques mots notamment
de la solidarité à la source
de remettre en activité des personnes on
est passé dans le cadre de
l'expérimentation de dix territoires à
63 ce qui correspondait à une demande
forte sur les territoires on a aussi
grandement favoriser l'emploi au sein
des structures d'insertion par
l'activité économique
avec 91 1800 postes qui ont été financés
en 2021 sans compter les 35000 postes
supplémentaires dans le cadre du plan de
relance à destination plus spécifique le
des jeunes
sur les publics car les plus en
difficulté notamment les publics en
situation de handicap on a fait le choix
d'augmenter considérablement les
entreprises adaptées en passant de 40
milles à 80000 places disponibles et il
ya en développement si les emplois deux
contre un pour sortir les des structures
et permettre permettre cette évolution
vers des entreprises plastique
accompagner les publics les plus en
difficulté s'est aussi déployée le s
pays donc aujourd'hui à 79 territoires
qui sont entrés dans ce pays à ce pays
un visant à mettre finalement un
référent unique autour du projet du
demandeur donc c'est quelque chose qui
me va trouver également tout son sens
dans l'accompagnement des bénéficiaires
des bénéficiaires du rsa ont toujours
sera accompagné pour accompagner les
publics les plus en difficulté et
notamment les jeunes dont on a vu qu'ils
étaient le plus fréquemment au chômage
on est considérablement doubler les
moyens les 200000 garantie jeanne en
2021 pour des taux d'insertion qui alors
mis 21 l'année 20 en 2020 qui étaient
compliqués sont spécialement intéressant
avec 76% de retours à l'emploi
l'apprentissage en jean noël l'a évoqué
on j formidablement à 10h en passant de
280 jeunes en 2017 à 718 jeunes
actuellement est donc actuellement j'en
ai également sur le déploiement du
contrat d'engagement jeunes qui
rencontrent un vif succès avec déjà 70
mille jeunes entrés dans un dispositif
en deux mois donc concernant la réforme
du rsa elle fait un peu peur mais à tort
parce que si on prend si on prend le
succès de du contrat d'engagement jeunes
dont témoignent les missions locales
c'est exactement la même logique il
s'agit pas même s'il ya pu avoir
peut-être des
dépts être des erreurs de langage un
certain moment de conditionner le rsa a
du travail le travail il doit être
rémunéré comme du travail il s'agit bien
m donc des personnes au rsa dans une
dynamique identique à celle du contrat
d'engagement jeunes c'est-à-dire de
l'accompagnement personnalisé des
ateliers et bien sûr ce qui est le plus
peut-être le plus mobilisateur des
périodes de stages en entreprise ou
d'immersion en entreprise
donc cette rs est jeune et doit pas
faire peur c'est un peu le héritier du
lpga le qu'on avait pensé dès le début
du quinquennat et qu'on n'a pas pu
mettre en oeuvre avec des contrariétés
qu'on a connus du fait de l'esprit de
l'épidémie donc là il revient il vise un
double objectif il vise à lutter contre
les nombreux courants quand on sait que
sur le sur le taux de 2 donnons de non
recours sur le rsa en est à 37 % et à
27% pour la tenue d'activités donc on
les rend en systématisant le versement
de ces prestations on lutte contre le
non recours le non recours qui a été
évalué à 5 milliards d'euros donc on
parle souvent de la fraude sociale y est
liées au rsa mais elle est estimée à 15
millions d'euros seulement donc on a
tout intérêt à eux contre seulement
beaucoup parce que lutter contre le
nombre pour ses luttes et bien sûr
contre la pauvreté et permettre
d'enclencher pour tout à chacun des
parcours de vie
enthousiasmant
merci beaucoup à vous qui nous avez
rappelé lors d'un autre atelier
effectivement à quel point cette
question du rsa c'était un
accompagnement nécessaire qu'ils
pouvaient être sur un temps assez long 1
selon l'éloignement ou les personnes se
trouvaient de l'emploi selon les
addictions qu'elle pouvait avoir selon
les parcours de chacun donc
effectivement il ya nécessité de temps
d'écouté
d'organisation est donc également on
voit que des personnes nées au rsa des
personnes isolées très éloignées de
l'emploi sont en souffrance mais on voit
aussi que dans une catégorie de
population qui a un emploi comme on l'a
vu au moment de la crise et gilet jaune
on peut aussi avoir finalement des
sentiment de mal-être ou de
rapports compliqués à son travail est ce
que par exemple les idées comme celle
que le mouvement démocrate porte depuis
longtemps de participation
d'intéressement à la vie des entreprises
permettrait de rapprocher les
travailleurs de leur de leur entreprise
et donc de donner du sens en fait à un
travail que l'on a mais voilà qui
évidemment est mieux vécu quand on s'y
attache
à peut-être pour michel
quand tu fais tu évoques probablement la
question de l'intéressement c'est ça la
partie 6 4 c'est une question
voilà peut-être que jean noël
et patrick de nos appartenances et sa
patrie qu'il est bloqué en savoie pour
une urgence et donc ils et voilà il
s'excuse il était seul et il a essayé de
tourner une petite vidéo mais il est il
est aphone en plus donc on pense d'abord
c'est intéressant en lui-même tel que
tel que le modem le propose je pense que
j'en parle peut-être que moi moi ce que
ce que je note parce que je suis très
investi dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire c'est qu'effectivement il faut
que le travail ait un sens et donc on
peut plein aujourd'hui je pense qu'on
n'accepte plus de travailler si on est
pas
si on trouve pas une motivation à le
faire et on voit c'est ce que c'est ce
qui se produit un petit peuvent
actuellement dans l'hôtellerie
restauration où on a des conditions des
situations absolument catastrophique de
personnes qui ne se présente plus pour
pour des embauches et il existe il
existe des solutions des leviers qu'on
me le dise peut-être pas suffisamment
selon moi au sein de ce qui se pratique
dans l'économie sociale et solidaire et
notamment à travers les coopératives il
faut savoir à leurs cesse ça représente
10% du pib 14 ans et 14 % des emplois
privés donc ces deux cent mille
entreprises et structures et devient de
38 millions de salariés donc parmi ces
structures il ya donc les coopératives
d'intérêt collectif et des coopératives
d'intérêt collectif
elles permettent d'associer finalement
des travailleurs les salariés une
direction des collectivités des clients
tout un microcosme de personnes qui sont
intéressées finalement pas relativité
qui est des poignets qu'ils peuvent tout
donc entrer comme actionnaire
dans la dans la société donc dans l'est
dans les stic les céleris ne sont pas
majoritaires elles peuvent devenir
majoritaire dans le cadre des sports
quoi qu'il en soit c'est ces modalités
qui représente aujourd'hui 71 1000
salariés ne demande qu'à se développer
actuellement si on regarde la carte de
france sur les coopératives on voit que
certains territoires comme la bretagne
sont très développées sur le sujet et
qu'on trouve des coopératives dans tous
les domaines de la vie économique
alors que dans d'autres territoires
notamment l'île de france on est très en
retard sur ces sources les modalités de
développement donc moi sur cette
question de l'intéressement des salariés
elle me paraît elle me paraît primordial
à des moyens qui paraît évident c'est
celui de l'économie sociale et solidaire
mais même dans les entreprises
classiques il faut prendre en compte ce
besoin de motivation des salariés à la
production
merci beaucoup michel j'en aurai sur
cette question de l'intéressement
oui donc sûr c'est évidemment un
sujet qu'on a beaucoup défendu que le
modem défendre les la question de de
l'intéressement et de la participation
c'est à dire le partage des profits
réalisés par les entreprises avec les
salariés eux aussi
je trouve que c'est un instrument encore
plus puissant le l'actionnariat salarié
qui conduit les salariés n'ont pas
seulement à partager les profits ou en
tout cas la croissance de la valeur des
entreprises mais aussi à partager le
pouvoir dans l'entreprise puisqu'ils
détiennent des droits de vote à travers
ces actions là beaucoup de choses ont
été faites pendant les cinq années qui
viennent de s'écouler pour développer
l'intéressement la participation ou
l'actionnariat salarié notamment en
réduisant les cotisations et les impôts
associés à ces versements par
l'employeur
et dans le dans le projet présidentiel
d'emmanuel macron il ya ce qu'on a
appelé le dividende salariés sans qu'on
comprenne toujours exactement ce dont il
s'agit le principe en est simple
désormais lorsqu'une entreprise
lorsqu'un chef d'entreprise versera des
dividendes à ses actionnaires aux
actionnaires de l'entreprise il devra
avoir mis en place au préalable une
forme de partage de la des bénéfices
avec ses salariés que ce soit de
l'intéressement que ce soit de la
participation que ce soit d'autres
outils comme ce qu'on appelle les
actions gratuites ou la prime macron
enfin c'est à dire la prime
exceptionnelle pour le pouvoir d'achat
qui existe depuis deux ans maintenant et
qui permet aux chefs d'entreprises de
verser à ses salariés une prime sans
impôts ni cotisation
cette prime va par ailleurs être triplés
dans ces plafonds qui vont passer de
1000 à 3000 euros pour le
pour le cas classique et de 2000 à 6000
euros pour certains cas exceptionnels et
donc cette obligation ou cette condition
conditionnalité
du du partage de la richesse au
versement du dividende
permettra sans doute un développement
très fort de ce partage de la valeur
ensuite il ya puisque tu parlais du de
la d2 l'insatisfaction au travail il ya
une autre
promesse présidentielle qui me paraît
très intéressante dont on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé pendant la campagne mais
qui est qui qui va vraiment le potentiel
qui a vraiment le potentiel de changer
la vie des gens c'est ce qu'on appelle
le compte épargne temps universel sur le
compte épargne temps pour les salariés
qui en bénéficient aujourd'hui on peut
accumuler des rtt on peut accumuler des
congés et puis le moment venu les
utiliser pour un engagement associatif
pour une formation une reconversion pour
interrompre tout simplement sa carrière
quand on le souhaite le problème de se
compter par du temps c'est d'abord que
tout le monde n'y a pas accès
c'est d'autre part que lorsqu'on passe
d'une entreprise à l'autre ou d'un
statut de salarié un statut
d'indépendant on perd le bénéfice de se
compter par du temps et le troisième
inconvénient c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne
peut pas vraiment le transformer en
complément de rémunération si on a un
problème pour financer un projet
et qu'on n'a pas les moyens financiers
de le faire la promesse d' emmanuel
macron c'est de rendre ce se compter par
du temps universel c'est-à-dire de dande
en ouvrir l'accès à tous les salariés
mais aussi à tous les indépendants de
faire en sorte qu'on le conserve tout au
long de sa carrière qu'on n'ouvre pas un
nouveau compte épargne temps quand on
entre dans une nouvelle entreprise par
exemple et enfin qu'on puisse non
seulement l'utiliser pour aménager sa
carrière et faire des interruptions si
nécessaire mais aussi qu'on puisse le
transformer en complément de salaire
merci alors l'idée de compte épargne
temps universel c'est une idée très très
forte est vraiment très séduisante parce
qu'elle porte en elle justement une
promesse d'autonomie c'est comment
finalement être acteur dans son travail
ne pas simplement le subir et ça prend
en compte toutes les évolutions de la
société donc par rapport à l'espace et
au temps donc les carrières qui sont
moins linéaire qui peuvent être
évidemment beaucoup plus
flexible haché qu'auparavant on peut
faire des reconversions donc vu comment
on n'est pas moins de linéarité ça c'est
cette mesure en tient compte et puis
même avec les confinements on a bien vu
le rapport à l'espace le développement
du télétravail donc le rapport au temps
et à l'espace a beaucoup évolué
récemment
oui c'est d'ailleurs une des rares
mesures proposées par les candidats sur
la ligne de départ pour l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 qui qui
s'attaquait si je puis dire à ces
mutations du travail je regrette qu'on
n'ait pas pu en parler plus que cela
pendant la campagne mais c'est vrai que
chez les autres candidats il y avait
très peu de réflexion menée sur sur
sexuelle
c'est vraiment enthousiasmant parce que
c'est comment justement donné envie de
travailler dans les meilleures
conditions et en plus en ne prenant pas
comme tu disais au pouvoir la décision
de la vie des entreprises
donc ce que ces cinq années ont permis
de voir aussi c'est vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure tous les deux énormément de
défauts remis pour l'apprentissage pour
la formation professionnelle vous
rappeliez des chiffres 1 700 mille
contrats signés en 2021 pour
l'apprentissage donc là aussi c'est
quelque chose qui est très en lien avec
ce qu'on défend au modem
la diversité des parcours professionnels
l'idée qui a pas une seule voie de
réussite possible et que donc la
diversité des métiers est quelque chose
qu'il faut valoriser au maximum
peut-être michel
oui le compte épargne et pourtant c'est
une
super idée c'est un peu dans la même
logique compte de que le compte
personnel de formation dont un en avoir
assuré la portabilité il ya maintenant
déjà longtemps mais en facilité d'en
faciliter l'usagé qu'on a réussi à faire
dans le cadre du quinquennat c'est
fondamental pour que chacun puisse
finalement c'est à nous y retrouver son
chemin on le sait ces cds concert de son
nom on voit bien qu'en perte d'activité
salariée à d'intimité indépendante que
l'on peut avoir envie de se réorienter
du tout au tout il ya des personnes qui
exerçaient des métiers de bureaux de
cadres et qui préfèrent retourner à la
terre qui prennent qui prennent des
quelque part de risque dans ses
activités donc aujourd'hui il ya un
certain nombre de dispositions qui sont
déjà prévues pour faciliter les
transitions mais comme le disait jean
noël elles sont elles sont partielles
alors elles sont mobilisables pour un
salarié qui va pouvoir demander une
suspension sont comptables travail le
temps de pour convenance personnelle
pour un autre projet mais ça peut être
refusée par par l'employeur et puis il
peut y avoir des congés de en partiel
pour la création ou la reprise
d'entreprise mais là encore ça peut être
refusée par l'employeur et on peut se
retrouver donc sans solution pour mener
à bien à bien ses projets et enfin le
projet de transition professionnelle lui
il est rémunéré par contre il vise
simplement à
en fait pour suivre une formation ont
changé de métier donc aujourd'hui on est
dans des dispositifs qui existent mais
qui sont épars et qui répondent pas
qu'il réponde pas à toutes les solutions
le contre temps universel permet de
répondre à toutes ces solutions voilà
c'est vraiment à une mesure
d'émancipation
je pense qu'on a pas mal avancé sur la
question de l'émancipation à travers
l'information mais le temps c'est aussi
parfois simplement le temps d'une le
temps d'une pause le temps d'une pause
familiale d'un projet le plus personnel
et ça doit être respectée aussi
merci beaucoup sur l'apprentissage tu
veux ajouter quelque chose
non l'objectif est d'aller plus loin
encore d'atteindre le million de
contrats d'apprentissage signés chaque
année
ce qui nous a permis d'arriver jusqu'à
730 milles ou 720 milles c'est dans un
premier temps de de lever un certain
nombre d'obstacles réglementaires qui
qui rendent l école et l'apprentissage
peu attractif à la fois pour les
employeurs et pour les jeunes et puis
dans un deuxième temps
après le début de la crise c'est le
lancement du plan un jeune solution avec
des primes assez significative pour tous
les recrutements en apprentissage qui
ont permis de poursuivre cette forte
croissance de l'apprentissage et donc
je pense qu'on a on a la gagne est une
forme de bataille culturelle puisque
aujourd'hui sont apprentis à la fois des
des personnes qui sont sur des
formations
avant bach ou infra bac mais aussi des
gens qui sont en licence ou en master
est donc désormais il n'y a plus aucun
stigmate culturelles associées à
l'apprentissage dans le le mandat qui
s'ouvre le nouveau challenge ce sera
d'avoir la même réussite avec les lycées
professionnels que ce qu'on a pu avoir
avec les centres de formation des
apprentis de faire en sorte que le lycée
professionnel soit mieux articuler avec
le collège pour que à l'issue du collège
les jeunes se tournent plus spontanément
vers les lycées professionnels que
pendant le courant de leur formation il
est une vraie
expérience du monde de l'entreprise et
encore des lycées professionnels
aujourd'hui où certains jeunes n'ont
aucune expérience d'alternance donc on
va multiplier les stages certains seront
même rémunérés par l'état et puis à
l'issue du lycée professionnel une
meilleure insertion sur le marché du
travail qui sera au programme de cette
grande réforme
merci oui effectivement que dès le
collège et puisse y avoir un contact
avec ce monde professionnel est
peut-être la naissance de vocation au
lieu de simplement considérer la voie
professionnelle comme une voie des
chèques mais de voir qu'au contraire il
ya de beaux métiers qui peuvent susciter
justement une envie alors on parle
d'entrer dans le monde du travail de
retour à l'emploi pour ceux qui ont
décroché également le travail ça suppose
la perspective de ce qui vient derrière
donc le moment on va le quitter la
retraite donc on a vu pendant la
campagne aussi cette question de la
retraite cristallisé certaines
interrogations ou certaines inquiétudes
et on le voit on en a parlé notamment
dans un atelier récents tout le monde
n'a pas le même rapport bien sûr à son
travail était
pour des personnes pour lesquelles la
retraite c'est quelque chose que l'on
attend avec impatience d'autres qui au
contraire redoutent ce moment comme un
couperet et souhaite continuer à
travailler et à cumuler emploi et
retraite durant des années parfois
longue donc qu'est-ce qui est prévu pour
justement
ces diverses situations pour le cumul
emploi retraite par exemple dans un
premier temps enfin pour plus de
flexibilité pour le travail des seniors
ou l'autre michel
alors qu'est ce qui est prévu pour
faciliter ce cumul en fait il s'agit de
permettre à certaines personnes qui
peuvent poursuivre leur activité
effectivement de de le faire dans de
meilleures conditions
aujourd'hui quand on arrive
on a je dis seigneur on a parfois du mal
à garder encore sa place dans
l'entreprise et ont donc en avant
première un jeu qui est de favoriser ses
fins de carrière ça ça me paraît
complètement primordial donc il ya des
dispositions qui existent pour notamment
vis-à-vis des employeurs pour aider à
aider un
conserver leur lancée niort je pense que
c'est quelque chose sur lequel on doit
être particulièrement vigilant on pourra
agir aussi sur le cumul avec le cupide
et des droits acquis une fois qu'on est
à la retraite parce que aujourd'hui on a
un petit on a un petit souci c'est que
si on peut valoriser sa retraite si on
ne s'en sort pas si on ne s'en sort pas
avec sa retraite en sortant et qu'on
veut commencer à apprendre eh ben on ne
peut pas pu m'y mets avec un emploi ou
si on cumule a varié avec un enfant on
peut mais ça ne ça me permet pas
d'enrichir les années à venir où on ne
pourra plus cumulé sept ans cet emploi
et 7,1 et cette retraite donc il ya un
travail que je pense à faire sur sur le
sujet
dans le cadre de cette réforme de la
retraite on me l'a reprendre les
objectifs qu'ils étaient
qui étaient les nôtres lorsqu'on a
commencé à une partie des objectifs qui
étaient les nôtres quand on a commencé à
travailler sur cette retraite
c'est-à-dire qu'on emprunte bien
évidemment les publics les publics les
plus fragiles qui ont une carrière
difficile d'être évident que cela ne
pouvons pas poursuivre leur activité
jusqu'à 64 ou 65 ans dans cette activité
il faudra arrêter plus tôt ou l'aménager
considérablement ça c'est un des
premiers points à prendre apprendre
c'est un pas prioritaire ce sera ok est
tellement l'occasion d'améliorer bien
sûr les
pensions de réversion dont on a vu qu'il
y avait une certaine injustice sur le
sujet puisque tout le monde touche pas
la même chose au même moment et l'enjeu
bien évidemment c'est aussi de relever
de relever des pensions de relever des
pensions minimums à 1100 euros ce qui
est vraiment un investissement important
est absolument nécessaire pour
reconnaître le travail des personnes
n'avaient dire des carrières complètes
mais avec des petits des beauty revenus
qu'est-ce que je je je je reviens mais
sous en question mais
merci voilà on passe la main à jean noël
forcément
oui donc sur la retraite je veux pas
michel a dit toutes les choses de
manière très exact simplement peut-être
tort le cou à une idée
très fausse qui consiste à dire que
quand on allonge l'âge de départ à la
retraite
quand on le repousse que ça crée du
chômage des seniors
c'est vrai qu'en france il ya un taux de
chômage des seniors qui est élevé mais
en réalité ce que nous montre les
expériences étrangères c'est que
lorsqu'on a repoussé l'âge de départ à
la retraite le taux de chômage des
seniors a baissé pourquoi est-ce qu'il a
baissé parce que
entreprises comme salariés seniors ont
tous deux une incitation à investir dans
la formation du salarié
aujourd'hui quand on est à deux trois
quatre ans de la retraite et que bien
l'avenir du poste n'est pas garanti
l'entreprise va avoir tendance à
proposer aux salariés de
des systèmes de pré retraite plutôt que
d'amener le salarié à trouver de
nouvelles opportunités y compris en en
enrichissant son propre capital humain
quand on repousse un peu l'âge de départ
à la retraite alors redonne des
incitations à la fois aux salariés et à
l'entreprise de d'investir dans ce
capital humain d'investir dans la
formation pour pouvoir poursuivre une
activité
d'autre part parce que c'est qu'il
s'agit pas juste de train de repousser
indéfiniment l'âge de départ à la
retraite pour le pour le plaisir il
s'agit de le faire pour financer notre
modèle social d'abord le système de
retraite en lui-même qu'il convient de
rendre plus robuste et plus justes donc
si on veut le rendre au buste il faut
qu'il soit équilibré financièrement si
on veut le rendre plus juste il faut
tenir compte de la pénibilité
il faut relever les pensions minimums il
faut tenir compte des carrières longues
et tout ça c'est un coût qui vous
financez et puis plus généralement le
fait de travailler un peu plus longtemps
c'est aussi des cotisations qui vont
rentrer pas seulement des cotisations
retraite mais en général c'est aussi de
là de la création de valeur de la
création de richesse qui vont permettre
de financer les services publics et la
solidarité donc c'est ça l'objectif de
cette réforme est il faut résister à
ces a priori infondée puisque les
expériences étrangères nous voulons
montrer qui consiste à dire que d'abord
on va allonger l'âge de départ à la
retraite pour tout le monde un défi rien
indifféremment quelle que soit la
pénibilité l'usure professionnelle et la
durée des carrières et d'autre part qu'
on se moque du travail des seniors
puisqu'il y avait comme michel l'a très
bien dit dans le le projet à la fois des
des propositions pour faciliter
l'engagement des seniors dans des
activités qu'ils soient pas
nécessairement des activités
professionnelles mais qui peuvent être
associative aux autres puis d'autre part
le renforcement des dispositifs cumul
emploi-retraite qu'on puisse continuer à
travailler tout en faisant valoir ses
droits à la retraite
oui la démographie l'imposent puisque
effectivement l'espérance de vie
augmente le vieillissement de la
population à une réalité donc c'est une
mesure cette réforme qui est absolument
nécessaire simplement peut-être alors
est-ce que sur justement la façon
d'associer les citoyens à cette réforme
sur des concertations sur des
consultations qu est ce que tu verrais
comme moyen peut-être apaisé certaines
inquiétudes
oui je pense qu'il y aura un
diagnostic qui sera posé des
concertations qui seront menées ensuite
je crois que vraiment la question qui
est posée là c'est c'est celle de
l'avenir du système de retraite par
répartition
on a le droit de est d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de personnes considèrent
que le système de retraite par
répartition n'est pas le meilleur
système de retraite que des systèmes de
retraite par capitalisation
fonctionnerait bien permettrait de
vendre est un certain nombre d'avantagés
et ses
avantages du système où j'ai l'avantagé
qu'ils mettraient aussi une exigence du
système de retraite par répartition
c'est qu'ils créent un lien de fait
entre les générations si on tire sur la
corde si on fragilise l'équilibré
financier du système vous aurez un
moment donné les générations qui sort
qui se dresseront les unes contre les
autres et qui diront et en particulier
là la suivante faire la prochaine qui
diront pourquoi est-ce que je cotise ray
alors même que je n'ai aucune garantie
moi d'avoir suffisamment d'actifs qui
cotiseront quand viendra mon tour d'être
pensionnés et cette génération là finira
un jour par élire quelqu'un dans 2 qui
proposera de basculer de la répartition
vers la capitalisation où c'est un peu
plus le chacun pour soi que dans la
répartition donc prudence c'est cette
cette réforme du système des retraites
chacun doit être bien conscient que ça
que ça n'implique que lui à titre
personnel mais que ça implique que ses
propres parents ainsi que ses propres
enfants et qui a quelque chose de très
fondamentale qui se joue ben ça dit
quelque chose de ce qu'est une société
de ce que c'est que faire société former
un tout solide et justement des liens
entre les générations et c c'est notre
vision humaniste de la société donc sans
laquelle effectivement
l'organisation politique et sociale perd
de son sens alors je vais me tourner
vers vers la salle pour prendre vos
questions
est-ce que donc vous avez des
question pour nous de nos deux députés
sur sur ce thème qui effectivement est
est essentielle
oui
est
ce que est ce qu'on n'aurait pas tant
trop tendance justement alors en france
sur le plan culturel a opposé puisqu'on
parle d'intergénérationnel les jeunes
aux vieux moi j'ai vraiment une
réflexion sur le sujet depuis très
longtemps puisqu'on parle le chômage des
jeunes le chômage des seniors séniorité
on sait pas très bien quand ça commence
moi je les ai vécus à 40 45 ans la
séniorité dans la finance ça commence
très jeunes parfois même à 35 je me
souviens d'un recrutement à 33 ans où
j'étais qualifié de seniors donc voila
moi je me demande si on n'a pas intérêt
à travailler sur une vision justement un
petit peu différente de la société ou
alors l'emploi et les retraites les deux
sont liés bien évidemment alors on va
quand quand on cherche des solutions
pour les jeunes il ya aussi un effet
d'éviction le dirait des plus âgés on
peut me dire ça à versements si je
travaille sur les seniors peut-être
évincer les jeunes alors là où j'ai
envie que culturellement on change un
peu de mentalité je parle de mentalité
là pour le coup en france je pense qu'il
ya des des personnes plus âgées que
l'âge n'est pas un signe forcément de
compétences ou d'incompétence de la même
façon
quatre ans passent tous ne pas être en
poste au sens du salariat ne l'est pas
il ya un autre sujet aussi puisque les
deux sont liés l'emploi et les retraites
on parle dans les réformes à venir
uniquement de personnes qui auraient
travaillé une carrière entière au nombre
au sens du nombre de trimestres or dans
lan dans le même temps on parle
d'émancipation voir d'arrêt un peu de
travail de compte épargne temps etc sauf
que pendant toutes ces périodes où
parfois vous changer de statut vous êtes
en mode start up vous revenez dans le
salariat vous êtes en profession
libérale tout ça ne se cumulent pas
forcément et on se retrouve avec des
gens qui n'auront pas de toute façon
alors semestre au bout du compte donc
les 1100 euros ne s'appliqueront pas
forcément donc il ya énormément alors la
réforme paramétrique je pense que il ya
énormément d'efforts de pédagogie à
faire il ya une mise à plat aussi parce
que parfois même les spécialistes ont du
mal à retrouvez il faut appeler un chat
un chat les financiers om sont des
spécialistes dans certains domaines et
ne connaissent pas forcément ce qui se
passe à côté donc moi j'ai envie qu'on
est peut-être au mouvement démocrate
alors on l'a déjà eu naturellement par
le passé mais une réflexion d'ensemble
sur nos mentalités peut-être à faire
évoluer un il ya du bon et du moins bon
dans toutes les sociétés on parle du
système de capitalisation il ya
effectivement le système de la
répartition moelleux parfois j'ai une
réflexion à me dire la chose suivante et
si on créait alors pas pour tout de
suite et bien évidemment une espèce de
revenu minimum universel de base de
retraite un peu comme on à rsa et puis
j'ai envie de dire quand on gagne
beaucoup d'argent on peut aussi
capitaliser
quand on ment donc donc donc on a or ce
sont les personnes qui cotisent le plus
qui ont le plus de retraite aussi demain
donc donc il ya vraiment une vision
alors je passe un peu de c'est une
anecdote mais je pense que on a besoin
de remettre vraiment l'ensemble à plat
le système de retraite à points qui
avait été évoquée antérieurement était
sans doute une très bonne idée
puisque ça permet de rentrer des notions
d'émancipation et de flexibilité de
changement de statut etc mais c'est un
tout et je vais arrêter de monopoliser
le micro mais mais très sincèrement je
pense qu'on a on a aussi un sujet de
deux mentalités et et traiter les choses
segment par segment jeunes contre vieux
d'ailleurs on oublie qu'entre les deux
il ya des 1000 dommage
c'est pas forcément fin on n'a pas
trouvé la solution donc c'est pour
s'adresser cette raison qu'on y
réfléchisse tous ensemble voilà c'est
martin
jean noël ou michel michel tu as
travaillé sur la question du revenu
universel notamment
oui oui merci ça fait vraiment écho à
des choses on a déjà disputé et qu'il ya
important de qu'il est important de de
continuer à débat
toutefois je pense que le mot notre
régime de répartition c'est un des
moyens de faire corps justement quand
même c'est un des moyens
d'associer
d'associer toute la chaîne doute la
chaîne de la vie à
la solidarité
pourquoi on traite des jeunes et des
vieux de manière séparée
jour eh bien parce qu'il ya des
difficultés qui apparaissent quand on
regarde
certains chiffres liés à la pauvreté lié
au chômage
les bâtons sur des catégories on
identifie des catégories on essaie de
trouver de trouver des solutions
pour ces catégories donc je sais pas si
si
si on est capable de me réfléchir
autrement je suis allée des idées pour
réfléchir autrement je pense qu'elles
sont bonnes à prendre le revenu peut
être qu'effectivement le revenu
universel c'est une façon de réfléchir
autrement et une façon d'en sortir
c'est pas le c'est pas le choix qui a
été c'est pas été le choix qui a été
fait alors je pense au sein du mouvement
démocrate il y avait quand même un
[Musique]
bonne une bonne appréciation de la vente
âge que ça pouvait porter
la crainte la famille et elle a exprimé
un rapport à un revenu universel
c'était celle de lâcher un petit peu la
notion de
la notion de travail
il ya un attachement très fort à la
valeur travail et on n'a pas trouvé le
moyen dans le cadre de ce quinquennat en
tout cas de faire en sorte que
l'on mette en place un revenu universel
qui
qui ne mettraient pas ou de côté la
valeur travail
c'est c'est quelque chose à débattre
encore et effectivement si on allait
dans cette logique de romieu universel
finalement d'activité mais qui serait
effectivement pour un petit peu un
caractère universel comme big bass on
pourrait envisager dans la continuité un
revenu universel de retraite mais c'est
vraiment un débat politique un débat
politique de fond je reviens donc un
tout petit peu sur ce régime par
répartition comme je les dis ça permet
de prendre en compte toute la chaîne et
dans ce travail qu'on a à faire sur les
retraites on a aussi à prendre en compte
la dimension
fondamentale aujourd'hui de la réponse
qu'on doit apporter à la question de
l'autonomie
donc ça aussi je ça dépasse largement le
cadre je pense d'une d'une réforme une
réforme paramétrique et il faut pas le
laisser de côté mais je pense que c'est
dans le viseur quand même de de cette
réforme donc je ne sais pas comment on
va la prendre en compte mais ça a été
pendant même dans le cadre du premier
débat qu'on a eu dans le cadre de ce
premier mandat
on cherchait les moyens de faire cette
articulation entre
l'autonomie et des maîtresses
merci beaucoup jean noël sur les
questions qui a soulevé martin oui ben
je je je rejoins
michel pour dire qu'effectivement bon
mais comme le le disait aussi martin on
regarde certains des sujets par par bloc
mais ils sont évidemment liés les uns
aux autres et de la même manière que le
la question de la retraite des retraites
est liée à celle de l'autonomie
celle
du revenu du travail the du revenu
minimum et celle de l'insertion dans
l'emploi c'est d'ailleurs un peu la
manière dont on la traitait pour le coup
dans le cadre de la campagne sont sont
liées aussi et donc il faut réussir à
trouver les passerelles sans quoi
effectivement les politiques publiques
qu'on mène parfois se trouve
déconnectées les unes des autres il faut
y être attentif
merci alors une question d'un internaute
l'emploi étudiant a baissé pendant le
coc vide est ce qu'il est possible de
trouver de nouvelles manières de
travailler pour faire face à la
précarité étudiante sans avoir
nécessairement besoin que les étudiants
travaillent
alors est d'aider les étudiants afin
leurs études sans qu'ils aient
nécessairement accumulé études et
travail
simplement pour pour signaler qu
effectivement la crise la faire paraître
effectivement le la grande précarité
la grande précarité des étudiants
qui ont été un petit peu
à les oublier mais les prix en retard au
niveau des considérations des
considérations économiques
parce que notamment mais il était privé
de ses deux ces fameux jobs jobs
étudiants qui sont assez sains ses
fondamentaux alors il ya des pistes
déjà je pense que la possibilité d'avoir
un petit un petit port quand on est
étudiant ce c'est
alors c'est pas quelque chose de 2 c'est
pas quelque chose de rédhibitoire mais
il ya une inégalité de fait entre
certaines personnes qui peuvent
poursuivre leurs études en étant
assez soutenus par leur famille et
d'autres beaucoup moins donc dès la
crise on a pris justement
le principe de pouvoir diriger des
étudiants qui étaient dans des
situations financières qui le
nécessitent l eau qu elles puissent être
reçus qu'elle puisse avoir mais une
évaluation par la mission locale et
qu'elles puissent percevoir 1 1
des aides dans le cadre de leur projet
dans le cadre de leur projet de
formation donc elles sont un peu prise
en compte à ce niveau là après d'une
manière générale il ya eu aussi des
idées qui se sont exprimées lors je ne
sais pas si elles vont trouver leur
traduction et l'on leur continuité dans
le cadre du prochain mandat
notamment c'est un espace guérini si je
me trompe pas
évoqué la possibilité d'un prêt étudiant
sur une somme qui permettrait de
l'alléger le poids de la ressource
financière dans le cadre des études donc
voilà c'est des pistes dépisteur pour
poursuivre pour effectivement qui est en
tout cas une égalité d une meilleure
égalité des chances entre les jeunes en
fonction de leur situation
de leur situation personnelle et
financière pour pouvoir mener à bien
leur étude
merci beaucoup monsieur
hu moi je voudrais savoir ce que peut on
dire un peu plus sur l'emploi pour les
personnes handicapées ou à mobilité
réduite
le redresse les retraites aussi pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite moi-même de
juifs ils ont
handicapé et il est vrai que c'est pas
toujours facile de trouver un emploi
adapté donc avez-vous des précisions
nous apporter je remercie
merci beaucoup
michel
voilà j'ai des singes a effectivement
donné quelques quelques grandes lignes
tout à l'heure mais l'emploi des
personnes en situation de handicap ça a
été vraiment un
désastre sur lequel on a inspecté
progresser je pense qu'on a
progressé on a progressé en faisant en
sorte
qu'on comprenne enfin que
l'entreprise doit devenir un fusible que
l'entreprise elle doit s'adapter aux
personnes et pas les personnes les
personnes à l'entreprise donc ça
nécessite des aménagements passe ça
nécessite effectivement de
l'accompagnement vis-à-vis des des
entreprises pour qu'elles sachent
comment comment répondre aux besoins
d'adaptation comment elles comment ils
peuvent être aidés ce qui a besoin
d'adaptation y compris financièrement ça
c'est la première chose le l'objectif
final l'objectif final c'est vrai
vivement que chaque la personne en
situation de handicap puissent trouver
un poste dans n'importe quelle
entreprise
quel ce qu'elles soient
publiques privées associatives après il
ya des personnes qui sont que vous
d'autres difficultés
que le handicap etc ont besoin de passer
aussi
par par départ d'autre part d'autres
étapes donc il ya les esat qu'on connaît
il ya les entreprises adaptées les
entreprises adaptées il ya une vraie
volonté d'en faire des entreprises
vraiment passerelle vers l'entreprise
classique c'est à dire quand on souhaite
qu'on saute d'une logique où les
personnes rentrent dans une structure
d'insertion et lyon handicap et
finalement il reste et qu'on les
accompagne pour permettre les
allers-retours parce que parfois il ya
besoin d'essais et puis ça marche pas il
faut retourner dans la situation
la situation première et ça on le perd
mais on le perd mais pour sécuriser les
personnes ça doit pas être il faut pas
avoir peur de laisser une situation pour
une autre qui présenteraient des
inconnus non c'est important de
sécuriser les personnes après concernant
le concernant le handicap jeu oui oui
donc vie du monde à cette question dans
le cadre du nouveau programme delà du
versement de la prime de lâches pour les
personnes en situation de handicap ça a
été un beau débat
récurrent on a eu trois ou quatre fois
dans le cadre du mandat selon versement
d'aidés personne en sortant de la pure
solidarité familiale et donc
nous on est très attachés en tant que
modem on s'est toujours dit très attaché
à cette solidarité familiale on était
attaché en revanche à ce que le plafond
soit relevé pour qu'effectivement
cette solidarité elles
prennent en quoi elle puisse aussi
nous prendre en compte le fait que 20
des personnes qui gagne modestement leur
vie ont besoin de ceux de ce revenu
complémentaire que pour être l'âge donc
le président a
dit son intention de retravailler encore
cette question
du maintien de l'emploi ou du ou 2 ou du
non emploi on sait pas possible avec une
allocation adulte handicapé
merci beaucoup michel effectivement plus
de cumuler de ressources et puis aussi
d'être inséré dans la société d'acquérir
une autonomie en travaillant et en ayant
justement le sentiment de faire
pleinement
pleinement partie du corps social est ce
que jean noël tu veux ajouter quelque
chose sur le handicap
d'autres alors d'autres d'autres
questions
n'hésitez pas sinon on a déjà dit
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses on a
évoqué pas mal de sujets mais si vous
avez une question même la plus technique
soit elle jean noël se fera un plaisir
de répondre à une question bien
compliqué ce regard peut-être
oui bonjour je vais revenir un petit peu
sur les aides pendant coronavirus et
notamment le quoi qu'il en coûte qui
quelque part a permis de sauver
énormément d'emplois puisque
factuellement ce n'était pas les
entreprises qu'ils étaient et des sites
et surtout les salariés ce qui a permis
de maintenir à l'emploi et et de
redémarrer système économique derrière
aujourd'hui ces aides sont petit à petit
en train d'être coupée est-ce qu'on ne
risque pas de couper la relance
économique et le rebond qui est en train
de se faire actuellement
merci pour rien pour cette excellente
question
les
les aides les mesures d'urgence c'est
vrai ont été progressivement éteinte
même si s'agissant de l'une d'entre
elles qui est bien connue des chefs
d'entreprise qu'on appelle les pge les
prêts garantis par l'état
il est encore possible d'en souscrire
mais il est vrai que dans l'ensemble les
aides ont été éteintes mais d'une part
le plan de relance continue de se
déployer dans notre pays
et d'autre part
le le
la crise que nous vivons du fait de la
guerre déclenchée par la russie en
ukraine
a fait l'objet d'une réponse très
vigoureuse de la part du gouvernement
d'abord pour préserver le
protéger les françaises et les français
de la très forte hausse du prix de
l'énergie et du carburant mais aussi
avec ce qu'on appelle le plan de
résilience un certain nombre de mesures
pour protéger les entreprises dans les
secteurs qui sont très fortement impacté
par par cette hausse des prix de
l'énergie mais là où là où il ya des
inquiétudes
qui sont réelles c'est pour un certain
nombre d'entreprises souvent des petites
et des moyennes entreprises qui se
retrouvent un peu coincé parce que
au-delà du prix de l'énergie dont j'ai
dit que le plan de résilience permettait
dé leur permettait d'absorber le choc il
ya une augmentation du prix d'un certain
nombre de matériaux de matières
premières qui pèsent très lourdement sur
les coûts de ces entreprises qui par
ailleurs n'ont pas nécessairement la
possibilité d'augmenter leurs propres
prix ce qui fait qu'elles se retrouvent
coincés avec des coûts qui augmentent
des prix qui ne peuvent pas augmenté
aussi fortement et donc des profits qui
deviennent négatifs et qui pourraient là
dans un certain nombre de situations
entraîner des entreprises vers la
faillite et donc ça va être un des
enjeux des semaines et mois qui viennent
et c'est pas simple parce que autant sur
sur certains sujets sur certains sur
certaines filières on identifie que les
hausses de prix sont transitoires
qu'elles proviennent de la forte
croissance mondiale depuis ce depuis
l'automne dernier et la désorganisation
des chaînes de production autant sur
d'autres filières il ya potentiellement
une inflation qui va durer et donc des
difficultés pour les entreprises qui
pourrait être persistante et donc des
réponses nouvelles à apporter à ces
entreprises
merci beaucoup merci a pu d'autres
questions peut-être un tout petit mot de
conclusion et puis
oui ça c'est une question d'argent
merci moi je suis important avec le
décalage de lors de la conférence
on ya certaines familles politiques qui
cherchent à dépasser le travail nous ici
c'est un motif de fierté qui est de
défendre le travail on pense que ça un
vecteur d'émancipation importante dans
notre société et je pense qu'on a raison
de continuer à le défendre c'est pour ça
qu'on a mis la bataille de l'emploi pôle
emploi pour la production en france en
haut de nos priorités depuis maintenant
de nombreuses années avec françois
bayrou notamment et on voit qu'elle est
en passe cette bataille pôle emploi
d'être gagné puisque maintenant on se
dirige tout droit vers le plein emploi
si tout se passe bien faut évidemment
toucher du bois le et est ce que
finalement il n'y a pas une deuxième
bataille qui s'engage sur la mobilité
dans le travail comme toujours comme
vecteur vecteur d'émancipation
on avait un modèle pendant les trente
glorieuses où finalement les salariés
les travailleurs notamment dans
l'industrie pouvait arriver en étant
ouvrier spécialisé puis passé
contremaître et puis voir parfois
atteindre le grade de cadre on avait des
institutions pour ça c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a une atomisation de
l'emploi on a des nouvelles nouveaux
emplois qui apparaissent qui se
développent et finalement depuis les
années peut-être la fin des années 80 et
90 on va cette mobilité qui se casse et
on a une difficulté dans le travail dans
l'emploi à avoir ces parcours de
réussite
au travers du travail et qu'est ce que
est ce que cette bataille est
aujourd'hui densifier ce que nous ça
pourrait pas être quelque chose qu'on
porte au sein du modem et qu'on découvre
cette nouvelle enfin qu'on redécouvre
c'est cet outil fin cette fonction du
travail alors un cheval de bataille pour
le modem allons aussi merci beaucoup
pierre-jean et oui je crois que tu as
raison de dire qu'on ne renonce pas à
l'idée que le travail puisse être un
vecteur de lien social
même si aujourd'hui dans un certain
nombre de situations il il ne joue pas
tout à fait ce rôle c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs certains de nos
concurrents ou certaines autres
formations politiques
proposent plutôt de revenir en arrière
et de faire
diminuer le travail dans dans la vie que
nous avons ce que je pense moi c'est que
l'un des grands thèmes qui va structurer
les années à venir et grâce à la
réélection des manuels macron nous
allons pouvoir en être
des artisans c'est la question de la
transition écologique parce que la
transition écologique
c'est un c'est une nouvelle frontière en
quelque sorte c'est un projet colossal
qui nous impacte tous quels que soient
notre âge quelle que soit la région dans
laquelle on vit quel que soit notre
classe sociale
donc c'est un projet unificateur pour le
pays c'est un projet industriel
parce que la transition écologique c'est
aussi faire en sorte que les entreprises
de france d'europe
se trouve en avance si je puis dire sur
les autres de la même manière que
kennedy voulais être le premier à poser
le pied sur la lune lorsque la situation
qui est déjà critique aujourd'hui va
devenir incontournable et que partout
dans le monde les effets du
réchauffement climatique vont se
manifester avec une telle brutalité que
la transition écologique se fera à
marche forcée si nous sommes nous
français nous européens les premiers à
avoir transformé nos modes de production
a transformé notre mode de travail nous
pourrons être
nous pourrons être à l'avant-garde de de
l'humanité sur ces sujets donc c'était
aussi un projet industriel mais c'est
enfin un projet
je dirais démocratique et ça ça nous
distingue nous vis-à-vis des des forces
politiques concurrentes je pense à
l'écologie jusqu'au boutiste de sandrine
rousseau qui ne s'embarrasse pas de
l'adhésion du consentement des citoyens
à la transition écologique et aux
sacrifices qu'elle qu'elle suppose je
pense qu à l'écologie de l'autre côté
l'écologie moindre et fortis tu de ceux
qui sont prêts à renoncer à la moindre
difficulté et nous ce que nous proposons
c'est une une écologie et ambitieuse
dans une écologie démocrate qui qui veut
poser un diagnostic dont nous espérons
qu'ils puissent être partagés face à la
réalité que nous a rappelé le giec
encore il ya peu et puis ensuite
une concertation sur les objectifs à
atteindre sur les moyens pour y parvenir
et des mesures d'accompagnement très
forte puisque cette transition
écologique allait parfaitement injuste
elles touchent de manière
très différenciée les secteurs
d'activités les territoires en
particulier donc une solidarité
nécessaire avec ceux qui en sont les
premières victimes de ces changements
importants qui s'imposent et ça nous
distingue aussi nous français nous
européens de du reste du monde dans le
reste du monde vous avez un certain des
régimes à commencer par le régime russe
qui veulent nous nous faire croire ou
nous amener à penser que la démocratie
est morte que démocratie n'est plus le
régime d'avenir et que dans les temps
qui viennent les régimes libéraux les
régimes beaucoup plus autoritaire
beaucoup plus descendants
seront plus efficaces face aux enjeux de
demain il nous appartient de faire la
démonstration qu'on ne peut réussir ce
gigantesque défi pour l'humanité qui la
transition écologique qu'en associant
très largement les citoyens à ces
changements là si nous faisons cette
triple
sept triples démonstration que la
transition écologique c'est à la fois un
projet unificateur pour le pour le pays
pour la nation pour le pays politique
que c'est un projet industriel c'est un
projet démocratique et sociale alors
nous aurons gagné cette bataille qui est
qu'il est indispensable de gagner mais
nous aurons aussi restaurer le travail
nous avons restauré la démocratie et
nous aurons restaurer l'unité du pays
un grand merci un très grand merci à
tous les deux michel jean noël grand
merci à vous également on se retrouve
mardi prochain pour un démocrate hebdo
sur l'europe et la guerre en ukraine
avec frédéric petit et sabine tillet
très bonne soirée et donc à très vite
[Musique]
à